Hi, I’m Adriene Hill, and welcome back to
Crash Course Statistics.
In the last episode we dove into the logic
surrounding test statistics and talked about
a general formula that allows us to create
them for lots different situations.
There are so many questions we might want to answer, and it would be rough if we had
to memorize a new formula for EVERY Single One.
And sometimes Statistics is taught in a way that makes it seem like there’s a different
formula you need to know if you want to test whether your bus is late more often than the
average bus in your town.
Or if burns treated with aloe heal faster
than those that are left alone.
But! Hah-zah.
We can adapt the general formula...in all
sorts of situations.
INTRO
Let’s say that you just moved to a new place, and you’re looking for the BEST coffee in town.
Since you’ve been watching Crash Course
Statistics, you decide to do a little impromptu experiment.
Word on the street is there are two really
popular coffee places near you, Caf-fiend
and The Blend Den.
So one Sunday after brunch, you grab a random sample of 16 of your new friends, and randomly
give half of them an unmarked cup with coffee from Caf-fiend, and the other half an unmarked
cup with coffee from The Blend Den.
You made sure to get the same roast--dark--to keep things as even as possible.
After delicate sniffs and sips of coffee in
a process known as “cupping”, the tallies are in.
On a scale of 1 to 10, Caf-fiend got a mean
score of 7.6 and The Blend Den got a mean
score of 7.9
So we observe a difference between the coffee scores.
Coffee from Caf-fiend scored 0.3 points lower than Coffee from The Blend Den.
So coffee from The Blend Den is better?
Right?
Done and done.
Nope not yet.
Maybe it’s just random chance.
So first we need to define our null.
There’s no difference between the two coffee shops.
And then our alternative hypothesis, that
there is a difference.
One is better than the other.
In this case, we’re interested in whether
the mean scores for coffee are different between
Caf-fiend and The Blend Den.
With a little algebra, we can see that this
is the same thing as asking whether the difference
between the two means is not zero.
Now that we have our hypotheses, we can do a t-test.
Specifically, we’ll do a two sample t-test,
also called an independent or unpaired t-test.
The formula for a two sample t-test follows
our general test statistic formula:
The difference we observed is 0.3.
If the null hypothesis were true and there’s
no difference between the coffee shops, we’d
expect a difference of 0.
So the numerator of our t-test is 0.3.
For this kind of t-test, our measure of average variation is the standard error.
For two groups, the standard error is calculated a bit differently since we have to account
for the sample variance of two groups.
Here, we’re squaring the standard deviation
to get the variance and n1 and n2 are the
sizes of the two groups--both are 8 here.
Now that we have our t-value, we can figure
out if there’s a statistically significant
difference between the two coffee shops and there are two ways to do this.
We can calculate the critical t-value and
if our t-statistic is GREATER than the critical
value we reject the null hypothesis.
Or we can calculate the p-value from our t-statistic and we can reject the null hypothesis if the
p-value is SMALLER than our chosen alpha level.
To do either of these things, we’ll need
to choose our alpha level.
Again, our alpha is arbitrary.
But usually people will use 0.05 since that
means that in the long run, only 5% of tests
done on groups with no real difference will
incorrectly reject the null.
So, we’ll conform :) and use an alpha of
0.05 here.
To calculate our critical t-value we need
to find the t-values which correspond to the
top 5% most extreme values in our t-distribution.
Usually a computer or a calculator will do
this for you, so we won’t go into the formula,
but here are the cutoffs:
The cutoffs for our specific problem are about -2.145 and 2.145.
We have two cutoffs because we’re doing
a two tailed test.
We want to reject the null if coffee from
Caf-fiend is better or if coffee from The
Blend Den is better.
We can already tell that we should fail to
reject the null.
That there’s no clear difference between
the quality of the coffee.
Our t-statistic of about 0.44 is isn’t close
to -2.145 OR 2.145.
The critical value and p-value approach will
give you identical results, so we don’t
really need to do both.
But for the sake of showing we get the same outcome…our calculated p-value is 0.6684.
We reject the null if the p-value is smaller
than alpha, so again we fail to reject since
0.6684 is WAY bigger than 0.05.
One thing that’s nice about the p-value
approach, and the reason we’ll mainly rely
on it throughout the rest of these examples, is that p-values are easier for us non-computers
to interpret.
A p-value of 0.6684 means that if there were NO difference in scores between coffee from
Caf-fiend and coffee from The Blend Den, we’d still expect to see a difference in our sample
means that’s 0.3 or greater pretty often...
66.84% of the time.
Since our observed difference of 0.3 or greater is pretty common under the null hypothesis,
we haven’t found evidence that it’s a
bad fit.
That’s why we failed to reject it.
So right now we don’t have any evidence
that one coffee shop is better than the other.
But remember, absence of evidence is not evidence of absence.
And while our coffee excursion and experiment were well designed, we can probably improve it.
If you look at the scores that your friends
gave the coffees, you’ll see that there’s
one person who tried coffee from Caf-fiend
and really hated it.
After looking through your scorecards, you
realize it’s Alex , who has mentioned in
the past that she just doesn’t love coffee.
Which gets you thinking.
Even though you randomly assigned your friends to get either coffee from Caf-fiend or coffee
from The Blend Den, that design didn’t account for the fact that some people just like coffee
more than others.
Alex might give the best coffee in the world
a measly 6 point rating just because...coffee’s
not really her thing.
Whereas your always caffeinated friend Cameron would probably give that day old coffee in
the breakroom a score of 7 just because he
loves coffee.
So in addition to any true difference in scores between coffee from Caf-fiend and coffee from
The Blend Den, our sample means are also affected by how much the people in each group like coffee.
You randomly assigned your friends to groups, so you don’t expect that there’s some
systematic difference between the average
coffee enjoyment of the groups.
But random assignment adds variation, which can make it harder to see a true difference
between the coffee scores.
One solution to this issue is a paired t-test.
You could try to pair up your friends based
on how much they like coffee and then randomly
assign one to coffee from Caf-fiend and the other to coffee from The Blend Den, and repeat
this over and over until everyone had been
assigned.
The best match, of course, for a person is
themselves.
I’m just like me.
So you decide to call another random sample of 16 of your friends.
This time you give all of them both Caf-fiend coffee AND The Blend Den coffee and they record
their scores.
Now that everyone has scored both coffees, you can be sure that the two groups have the
exact same level of “coffee affinity”
since it’s the exact same people.
The mean scores are still affected by variation due to individual coffee preferences, but
since the exact same people are in both groups, we can extract that variation and “throw
it away” so to speak.
One way to do this, is to make a difference
score for each person.
This will tell you how much more they like
coffee from Caf-fiend than coffee from The Blend Den.
Now that we have only one list of values--the difference scores--our matched pairs t-test
will look surprisingly similar to the one
sample t-test that we’ve seen before.
We observed a mean difference (Caf-fiend - The Blend Den) of -0.18125, which means that on
average, people rated coffee The Blend Den
0.18125 points higher than coffee from Caf-fiend.
The null hypothesis here is that there’s
no difference between ratings for coffee from
Caf-fiend and coffee The Blend Den, so we’d expect our mean difference to be 0.
And our measure of average variation is just the standard error of the difference scores:
Putting it together, we get a t-statistic
of about -3.212.
Before we get to the corresponding p-value
that our computer spit out, let’s consider
another way to think about what t-statistics
are actually telling us.
T-statistics tell you how many standard errors away from the mean our observed difference is.
Though the t-distribution isn’t EXACTLY
normal, it’s reasonably close, so we can
use our intuition about normal distributions
to understand our t-values.
Normal distributions have about 68% of their data within one standard deviation from the mean.
And about 95% within 2 standard deviations.
That means that t-scores around 3, like ours, are about 3 standard errors away from the
mean...only around 0.3% of scores are that
far away!
So it makes sense that our p-value is very
small: 0.00582.
Which allows us to reject the null hypothesis that there is no difference between the scores
for Coffee from Caf-fiend and coffee from
The Blend Den.
Which means that from now on, I’ll be buying my coffee from The Blend Den.
Except for when I’m meeting up with Alex,
then I’ll buy` tea.
Statistical tests help us wade through the
murky waters of variability, and our goal
should be to get rid of as MUCH of that variability as possible so that we can see patterns.
We can see whether exercise improves sleep...which your friends might be lacking after all that coffee.
Or whether your hearing could be hurt by listening to loud music by Cream or Ice Cube or Vanilla Ice
or some other musician that sounds like
it belongs in coffee.
Like Spoon! Spoon. Yeah? Brandon Spoon.
But more importantly, we’re learning that
all those formulas you may have seen floating
around, really aren’t that different.
We’re just comparing what we see, to what
we think we should see.
We’re always comparing the way things are
to how we expect them to be.
And statistics is no exception.
We now have the tools to design experiments and answer a lot of interesting questions
and do our own experiments even if we over caffeinate some of our friends in  the process.
Thanks for watching. I'll see you next time.